hello everybody
can everyone hear me
so my name is eleanor sterling and i'm
the director of the center for
biodiversity and conservation at the
american museum of natural history in
new york and i have the pleasure of
introducing this wonderful event this
evening
um and what i'm going to do is just give
a really quick overview to some of the
thoughts and ideas that we have for
today and then introduce a bunch of
other people who will introduce a bunch
of other people because we are after all
in a panel
and i should have asked how to advance
the slides
so today we're going to talk about the
nexus of art and science and
art science in nature
and basically my argument is that art
and science both navigate to the
relationships between humans and the
world that they live in
and they're both ways of knowing and
investigating the world around us and of
understanding our interactions with
nature
they're both also especially pre-modern
art grounded in close observation of the
natural world
in both art and science we search for
patterns and relationships across
various sets of information and
knowledge systems from genetic analyses
to wagnerian operas we'll explore motifs
or patterns i don't know if anybody read
the new york times blog on that the
other day but if you're interested come
ask me about it afterwards
and those patterns are repeated in
various ways in a larger work
art and science both develop imaginative
forms and processes and solutions that
communicate or create new relationships
across disciplines so these are various
ways that in my mind art and science
unite especially over nature
i think i might be doing this panel
because
because james is a friend and he's
trying to torture me no but also because
i taught a class a long time ago at
columbia university on
the
interpretations of nature
um and i taught it with a humanist who
was looking at nature in madagascar from
the perspective and artist
and the literature in madagascar and
then i of course brought some of the
scientific perspectives
and the people in the class were
really didn't gut at the beginning why
we thought that you could take
various ways of looking at nature in
madagascar and and start with art and
move through to scientific papers and a
lot of them were bankers from new york
and hadn't really read scientific papers
previously and it was really exciting
for us to
explore the the critique of ideas and
information to look for evidence in
anything that you're doing in art in
in your scientific arguments to be able
to understand better something
so i'm also supposed to talk a little
bit about how art intersects with the
work that i do at the museum of natural
history and of course
some of the most obvious ways that it
intersects is with
depicting the animals and plants that we
work with this is a beautiful set of
drawings by joyce powzick from here from
connecticut who uh who illustrated a
book on the vietnam natural history
by yale university press
and so monographs and field guides
you're going to hear a little bit more
about field guides later and of course
our iconic dioramas
are wonderful
examples of art that people don't even
think about as they're going through the
museum
and seeing the natural world itself
interacting with these gorgeous
backdrops is is another way that science
and art unites
in a seamless way
we also use art in our temporary
exhibitions i curated an exhibit on
water
a couple of years ago and i insisted
that instead of having some text on the
wall that it talks about the various
ways that water is found on earth in its
gaseous
solid and liquid phase we made a
sculpture that kids can interact with to
get that science across that science
fact across
and that kind of thing
we try to iterate over and over we also
used um edward bertinski's three three
gorges dam photographs he's a phenomenal
photographer to talk about some of the
water issues
and we're doing an exhibit on food
and i won't tell you exactly what's in
there in terms of art but i will tell
you you're using a lot of art in that
and this is just
some of the art that we explored this is
the shanghai expo from 2010
and heatherwick studio did this amazing
building this is a huge building these
are people standing outside the building
and these are all each one of these is a
rod that has seeds it's called the seed
pavilion and again it's a way to explore
art
through various media of art and nature
through the media of science as well as
art so other ways that we work in the
museum on art is through ground
landscaping we try to plant native
plants and think about ways to make that
beautiful for the neighbors who think
that native plants might be just weeds
the building architecture the the public
programs and global kitchen programs and
exploring the culinary arts so lots and
lots of different ways that we feel that
art and
science come together in the exploration
of nature
um there are also a lot of ways that um
art and science are divided in our in
our lives and elizabeth cinnamon
aristotle is going to come up and talk
to us a little bit about that
she herself is an artist and a quail
farmer
who
uh he's gonna spend a little time
chatting with us and then also introduce
the panelists so thank you very much for
listening to these introductory remarks
and let's welcome elizabeth aristotle
you just messed me up i listened to your
talk and i crossed out a lot of things
and i have to find them again
um i am elizabeth cinema neristoff i am
an artist and a member of the yales
institute for biospheric studies
advisory committee
it is my great pleasure to introduce our
distinguished speakers today at yale for
this wonderful event the art of nature
and the nature of art exploring the
reunion of arts and biodiversity
sciences
today we hope to explore the connection
between two areas of human inquiry that
arise from the same source the desire
the wish to make sense of and understand
the world around us but these two have
drifted apart so much so that their
individual vocabularies have become
nearly foreign to one another
this symposium arose from a desire to
reintegrate and reinvigorate art and
science our speakers come from a variety
of disciplines we have with us artists
art historians biologists
but all of these have a shared love of
both art and science and the wellspring
that inspires us to be inquisitive which
is nature
our first speakers are amy myers and
robert peck
amy myers director of the yale center of
british art has written extensively
about natural history and art her books
include mark catesby's new world vision
and the recently released knowing about
me
knowing nature
wonderful wonderful book
it's art and science in philadelphia
1740-1840 a project she began as curator
of american art at huntington library in
california and continued at yale is a
truly beautiful book
robert peck is a curator of arts and
artifacts and senior fellow at the
academy of natural sciences in
philadelphia he is a writer a naturalist
historian and world traveler
bob recently published a monumental book
on the history of the academy
of natural science
i have to feel like an ad
everybody this amazing book again um
it is a
sorry a celebration of the academy's
200th anniversary
he is currently working on a book and
exhibition about the parrot paintings of
edward lear
please welcome
amy and
sorry
this one
thank you so much liz and um may i just
say that
as the director of another unit at yale
i am so delighted to be part of this
program today
um i should know just before i begin
that i did my doctoral work here at yale
many many decades ago as an american
studies phd and
really it's out of that work
too many years ago than i can say that
this project about which i'll say just a
few words today
began but i couldn't have imagined a
center like this which would bring us
all together
in the extraordinary way that you are
and i hope that this presages
a really remarkable set of
cross-disciplinary
discussions i think that
this center and the center for
the frankie center for science and the
humanities at yale our natural partners
but we at the yale center for british
art hope that we'll be able to partner
with you as well on many projects into
the future so thank you for including me
and thank you for your kind words liz
over the course of the 18th century the
relatively open and permissive
intellectual society of quaker
philadelphia the largest and wealthiest
metropolis of the british colonies in
the transatlantic world
fostered an especially keen
receptiveness to the new science and as
the sociologist digby bald cell has
written brought the enlightenment to
america i hope there are no bostonians
sitting in this audience
the culture of science that developed in
this major intellectual hub of the
colonial world and that extended
ultimately into the 19th century and
beyond is the focus of the two books
that bob peck and i have edited recently
in bob's case a glorious enterprise the
academy of natural sciences of
philadelphia and the making of american
science the magnificent publication
accompanying a rich series of
exhibitions and programs celebrating the
academy's 200th anniversary mounted over
the course of this year
and in mine knowing nature art and
science in philadelphia 1740-1840
a set of 14 essays by a range of
distinguished art historians social and
political historians and historians of
science that offer a dynamic picture of
how the visual and material
interpretation of the natural world
functioned not only in
colonial and early republican science
but across the culture of the period
more generally
as close collegial friends
bob and i have been working together on
these topics for over for 30 years i met
bob when i was working on my
dissertation here so that was a long
time ago
indeed bob authored an essay in my book
and so we are delighted indeed honored
to introduce you to our related projects
together this afternoon
i will begin our joint presentation with
a brief overview of the wide-ranging
subjects covered in knowing nature after
which bob will discuss his own
publication and the academy programs to
which it speaks
the essays that comprise knowing nature
elucidate a multiplicity of ways in
which a pervasive interest in nature
fostered in philadelphia for spiritual
aesthetic economic and political ends
affected those processes of making
traditionally associated with scientific
practice of the day
such as the crafting of cabinets of
curiosity menageries botanic gardens and
images of natural productions
and of the limitless examples i might
have chosen i show you here a drawing of
the garden of the botanist john bartram
my his son william
in
which was executed in 1758 and played 35
in volume 4 of alexander wilson's
american ornithology
or the natural history of birds in the
united states published in philadelphia
between 1808 and 1914
a radical scottish weaver who emigrated
to north america and supported himself
as a school teacher wilson was mentored
as a naturalist artist by william
bartram in the family's garden i was
encouraged by william to produce the
first illustrated book on north american
birds to be published on this continent
and i know the subject is deeply
meaningful to us here at yale so i
thought that you might want to see what
those first images might have looked
like
while examining the plethora of
materials produced directly in
conversation
with science indeed often
self-consciously in its service knowing
nature also charts those activities not
ordinarily linked to scientific practice
that involve the close study of nature
from the design and production of
textiles and garments decorative arts
objects domestic and institutional
interiors and architectural structures
to the mapping of land and the reshaping
of its contours through agricultural
production and again of the infinite
numbers of objects and images that might
be shown as examples
i show you here objects that resulted
from such close observations of the
natural world one of the first pieces of
american soft porcelain pastry a pickle
stand decorated with small shells cast
from real mollusks by um
and anthony george anthony morris in
philadelphia in the first years of the
1770s we can't date the stand exactly
but these little shells that you see
along the stem were actually collected
studied and then cast as part of the
larger image which would have connoted
hospitality and genera generosity in the
form of the scallop shells which then
have an iconographic
importance
and also a bed cover from about 1800
made from floral fabrics that were
based on studies of the natural world
birds and flowers that were block
printed by the fabric producer john
hewson an astute study of nature in his
own right
the often surprisingly intimate
connections between and among those
observing nature directly in the service
of science and those doing so for other
ends are examined closely through the
essays in this book
calling into question the hierarchy that
is generally assumed to have been at
play in the study of the natural world
from the natural sciences through the
fine and decorative arts and ultimately
through popular and material culture
indeed
the many ways in which the process of
coming to know nature was essentially
reversed in which artistic and artisanal
culture informed scientific
interpretations of the natural world
might be considered a central theme of
the book
the general supposition that science was
the province of gentleman alone is also
challenged and how artists and
craftspeople with their special
knowledge of natural materials came into
conversation with those investigating
nature for theoretical and practical
purposes of science is explored for many
vantage points on the screen for example
you see an image of the exclamation of
the mastodon painted between 1806 and
1808 by the philadelphia artist and
museum director charles wilson peel tomb
the peabody of course's great debt to
celebrate the success of the partially
mechanized system that peel developed to
extract from the grounds of a farm in
shawwalgunk new york the bones of three
mastodons from which he would construct
the first complete skeleton of the beast
ever assembled
peel shows in this work the entire range
of workers invested in this heroic
challenge
from the day laborers operating the
machine and extracting the bones from
the pit
through family members and scientific
colleagues helping him to direct the
process and to conceptualize the
skeleton through the art of drawing and
you can see peel holding his great
drawing that symbolically attaches two
of the bones through which he's worked
out this process
that's held up by various family members
who are part of his team so to speak so
this is very much about communal
and cross-disciplinary enterprise which
involves a vast array of people and
their professions not simply academy
trained scientists um
and it's just of course at the time when
specialization is emerging and
philadelphia is becoming a real center
of specialized science but peel won't
let you forget
that that science can't be done without
a very intimately
linked and vast array of specialists
each in their own right contributing to
the process
in short knowing nature presents a group
of case studies that upset the
traditional hierarchical view of the
production of knowledge which dictates
that science informs art a hierarchical
view that has hindered a clear
understanding of how analytical
approaches to the natural world
developed during the 18th and early 19th
centuries
and so doing these case studies place
central importance on creative processes
and object types not usually considered
as relevant to the history of science
at the same time these examinations also
explore the ways in which those creative
processes and object types which
customarily have been associated
exclusively with scientific practice
actually functioned in many cultural
arenas
you're looking at my favorite drawing
focused analyses illustrate for example
that objects which naturalists seem to
have crafted solely for the purposes of
science
often served as social commentary or
autobiographical reflection evidencing
both the self-conscious interest taken
by naturalists who made them and the
overlapping communities of which they
were apart
and their own roles in these various
spheres and i show you here
a particularly powerful instance of this
a botanical drawing by william bartram
made in 1796 to illustrate one of his
new discoveries from the new jersey side
of the delaware river an orchid he
called arithuza devarakata
yet the image is far more than a
scientific illustration intended to
define the attributes of the species and
you can see this very tall
orchid which he
causes to stretch across the whole of
the paper vertically but there's so much
more that's going on in this image
along with the date of the drawing and
his signature of artist bartram
inscribed his venerable age then of 56
years old
explicitly marking the moment when he
portrayed his new find in the history of
his own career
indeed he shows the specimen as growing
from a great piece of turf including
other notable discoveries from across
much of his that distinguished career
going back to the tippity wichit or the
venus fly trap of which he made the
first drawing while visiting his uncle
on the cape fear river in north carolina
from 1761 to 1762
and if you look at the base of the
arthusa just run your eye down you'll
see
a sundew at the very bottom and just
your eye travels left and you'll see the
venus fly trap with its open trap on the
very far left hand
bottom part of the drawing
that drawing the one that he made in the
1760s to illustrate the tippity witchett
and the seeds and specimens he collected
had been sent by his father john to his
english colleagues among whom the plant
described by linnaeus as miraculum
natore would cause a sensation
now many decades later in his drawing of
arathusa from the late
1790s william poses the specimen and its
forebearers in his pantheon of plant
discoveries against the city of
philadelphia which had matured into a
major international national
metropolis and tandem with the growth of
the bartram's own garden creating an
autobiographical work that meshes the
history of the city into which he and
his family were inscribed so
significantly as naturalists
indeed as many of the essays that
constitute knowing nature demonstrate
during this critical period of the
development of north american science as
the united states emerged as a young
republic many philadelphia naturalists
as members of the leading scientific
community of the transatlantic world
thought seriously about their communal
ties locally regionally and
internationally taking into
consideration a complex of major factors
a real matrix
including national origin ethnicity race
gender
regional
political affiliation religion economic
interests and class and meshing these
into their analysis of the national the
natural world
such considerations surface frequently
in their work helping us to understand
how these early investigators bound
themselves to some communities and
distinguish themselves from others
created a creating a complicated indeed
kaleidoscopic world of
complementary and competing interests in
the natural productions of north america
these meditations on self-definition and
communal affiliation form a
critical strand that runs through the
essays that constitute knowing nature
charting a century of monumental changes
during which time philadelphia shifted
in status from the largest and most
affluent colonial city of british north
america
and of the british empire of course to
the capital of the new republic and
finally to one of several competing
centers of political social and cultural
influence these examinations demonstrate
how the study of the material and
artistic culture of science can
illuminate much broader societal
attitudes and trends
indeed neither as definitive nor is
comprehensive this collection of essays
points the way to further
cross-disciplinary studies in which
objects made to promote an understanding
of nature can be seen to reflect the
aspirations and anxieties
the successes and failures of the larger
cultures of which they were apart
and of course we will hope that this
center and those across yale that unite
this cross-disciplinary
pursuit will help us forward in our
understanding of this complex
intellectual matrix
that begins to be discussed in this book
by way of reflection i leave you here
with an image of charles wilson peel
i'm standing in his um great museum as
he depicted himself in 1822
thinking hard about his role and the
many communities of which he
of course was a part as well as those to
whom he would introduce these
communities through the museum as a site
of learning
and we of course have several of those
major sites of like kinds at yale the
peabody being first and foremost bob
will say a few more words about this
image as he talks about the academy of
natural sciences so i'm delighted to
hand over the podium
thank you
and this one's yours
and you are good to go okay good
thank you amy uh and good afternoon
everyone delighted to be here at part of
this
uh i'm gonna pick up right where amy
left off with this well-known image of
charles wilson peel in his museum
because he probably better than any
single person embodies this overlap of
science and art in the early 19th
century and i'm thinking in particular
the way he displayed his
collections in his museum with these
wonderful dioramas a detail of which
were revealed in
titian ramsey peel's study for his
father's self-portrait
unfortunately none of the dioramas
survive and we don't have very good
detailed descriptions of them but we do
have some images that were almost
certainly derived from them amy
mentioned alexander wilson earlier and
i'm showing you a plate another play
from american ornithology the bald eagle
as with many of the other birds in his
book was drawn from a specimen in peels
museum we think that possibly the
background was based on the diorama
itself so this may be the only surviving
depiction of what one of the peel
dioramas looked like and it shows ways
in which peel's art
had a ripple effect through other
artists into the outside world through
publications
this very similar posed eagle by audubon
it may have come from the same source
obviously audubon knew the eagle well
and and drew
from his own experience but he also may
have based his work
either on wilson's which would make it a
second generation removed from peels
museum or perhaps on peel's diorama
itself
the picture was criticized by george ord
and charles waterton and others as being
copied from wilson
and there certainly are some
similarities but i think more likely
they had a common source
in the dioramas
peels museum was very much a popular
museum he was charging admission he
wanted the public to come and see it and
he had not only mounted specimens and
preserved specimens of all sorts but
even live specimens including a pair of
grizzly bear cubs that were presented to
him
through
courtesy of
thomas jefferson but from zubal on pike
on one of his western expeditions
the cubs were very cute at first but
then of course they grew up and became a
little bit more unruly and sadly when
one of them escaped peel had to kill it
and then killed its sibling uh titian
peel made this drawing of them after
they were mounted for display and then
that picture was in turn copied by
thomas dowdy and published and
disseminated much more widely through
the cabinet of natural history of a
popular magazine of the period
so peel had huge effect even to those
who didn't have the chance to actually
visit his museum in philadelphia
visual imagery was of course the the
language of exchange internationally
during that period and i show uh just as
an example of george cuvier's plate of
mastodon teeth
so that this dialogue went both ways
across the atlantic uh specimens were at
the heart of these
these discussions and the academy of
natural sciences which was founded in
1812 the same time peels museum was
was operating was very much focused on
the specimens and on the scientific
exchange of information
and i wanted to differentiate between
the two and you'll see as they go along
as peels museum actually began to
decline from the 1820s into the 40s when
it was finally dissolved
the academy of natural sciences was
moving in the opposite direction it was
growing in numbers and particularly in
the size of its collections
and i show you here just a range of some
of the images the buildings that the
academy occupied from its founding in
1812 up until its current building built
in 1876. unfortunately we don't have as
many interior views of these museum
buildings as i wish we did
we do have a few
including interestingly the one in the
upper left-hand corner is alleged to be
the earliest interior photograph of a
museum existing this is a dagaria type
which shows among other people
edgar allan poe who was then doing shell
studies at the academy
but as you can see from all of these
images even up until 1900 the museum was
pretty much a collection of specimens it
was case after case after case arranged
systematically for the use of the
members although it was open to the
public from 1827 on
the public entertainment was not the
primary mission of the academy of
natural sciences
all of that changed quite abruptly in
1868 not at the
instigation of the academy but almost by
serendipity the british artist benjamin
waterhouse hawkins who had made his
reputation by creating the first
live-sized
sculptures of dinosaurs for the crystal
palace in london in 1853 came to america
specifically to new york to build a
paleozoic museum as it was called and
since there were no other experts on
dinosaurs at the time he came to
philadelphia and spent a good deal of
time at the academy in thanks for all
the help that he received there
he presented the academy with a fully
articulated dinosaur skeleton the
skeleton had been found by academy
members and described by joseph lighty
at the academy
waterhouse hawkins thought that it would
be good to show it in its life-like
posture you see him there underneath the
sculpture on the left hand side
this is a bit of a take off from charles
wilson peel's own erection of the
mastodon skeleton in his museum but
surprisingly 1868 this was the first
articulated dinosaur to be seen in any
museum anywhere in the world
and the effect was enormous in the first
year after it was put on display a
hundred thousand visitors came to the
museum to see it and this was at a time
when the museum was only open to the
public for two afternoons a week and it
was closed for the month of august and
july july and august so we're talking
about
40 or 50 days and 100 000 people coming
to visit it
art had clearly taken science to a new
level and made it a popular phenomenon
the end of the 19th century the academy
commissioned the blaschka studio
the same ones known for having made the
glass flowers at harvard
to create a series of displays of
invertebrates marine invertebrates in
this case an anemone uh which were
dazzlingly beautiful and we look at them
today as works of art i'm sure that the
curators who commissioned this work to
be done saw them simply as glass
reproductions of scientific specimens
but it's it's it raises this interesting
overlap of where is where does art begin
and science end
in the 20th century the academy
changed the superficial exterior
appearance of the building removing the
gothic revival facade and replacing it
with a sort of federal
building as part of the city beautiful
movement
and inside dramatic changes were soon to
occur as well
from the 18 from the 1920s through the
60s following the lead of our younger
sister institution the american museum
in new york
and others the academy began developing
a series of dioramas you see here just a
small model
by the jonas brothers studios
these projects as as we know well
from steve quinn's book and from work
michael anderson is doing here at yale
took
a great team effort as amy refers to it
was taxidermists painters
specialists of all kinds to artificially
recreate a lifelike habitat in three
dimensions many of these dioramas still
exist at the academy as they do here at
the peabody and
at the american museum
in more recent times the academy has
focused specifically on the overlap of
science and art by creating
something that we call the art of
science gallery and in this space we do
periodic exhibits by creative artists
contemporary artists
some of them quite whimsical in nature
others more seriously scientific
one of our speakers later this afternoon
james proczek will be exhibiting in the
art of science gallery later this year
but it is a wonderful place that brings
together the communities of art and
science we also thought that when we did
our bicentennial book
we wanted the book not only to reflect
the history of the institution but it's
its place in contemporary america and we
commissioned rosman purcell to make
photographs from our collections
many of you know rosman's work she's a
boston-based photographer who worked
closely with stephen j gould on a number
of books and many of her own as well
she's photographed in museums all over
the world but i think she is perhaps the
best of the contemporary photographers
in in
making scientific specimens of interest
to the art community
as well as to the scientific community
two weeks ago we opened a bicentennial
exhibit at the academy which really
brings us full circle it puts specimens
back on display again but i think some
of our founders would be surprised
perhaps even puzzled by the way we've
done this
these were arranged for purely aesthetic
purposes
there's no information except on a
separate card about what they are so as
our founders would have arranged them
all taxonomically and had
long explanations of what everything was
and how they related to each other these
were chosen to attract the interest of
the public and and to
reinsert the aesthetic
importance of science
into the public dialogue
we were told to keep our presentations
very short so that that's a
200 year history in
in less than 10 minutes but i invite any
of you who would like to come to
philadelphia and help us continue the
exploration of science and art thank you
alexis rockman is a new york painter
whose epic works tackle major nature and
climate issues including global warming
and genetic engineering
he was greatly influenced as a child by
the american museum of natural history
where his mother diana wall worked for
anthropologist margaret mead
he has exhibited many important
institutions including mass moca and the
brooklyn museum and was given a
retrospective at the smithsonian
american art museum last year please
welcome alexis
and yours
so we're going to try to get the cursor
to be
yeah
thank you very much
thank you very much
there you go great
okay i've 12 minutes
where's the clock um oh there it is okay
so um
first of all it's great to be here and i
want to thank james for inviting me
where is james
there he is you'll hear from him later
um
what i want to talk about today briefly
is this sort of hybrid world that i live
in um give you a little background about
my
childhood i grew up in manhattan i'm a
city kid and spent a lot of time going
to the bronx zoo and the museum of
natural history
whenever i would look at these
official versions of the history of
um natural history i was always very
aware that there was a story that wasn't
being told about how humans have
interacted with um the rest of nature on
this planet so to make a long story
short i'm going to talk about how
i've tried to cope with that information
and make paintings and images about
a kind of irreconcilable
tension between humans and the rest of
nature
obviously this is an image of um
you know enormous power um
everywhere that i've been
in my travels
and i do a lot of traveling for my work
with my family which has made it a lot
easier over the years and my partner's
sitting in the audience
is to
go to places that seem to be under a
certain amount of stress which is pretty
much everywhere including antarctica
tasmania madagascar
and see for myself
some of the impact that humans have
like finding dandelions in tasmania so
on and so forth so
what i've tried to do is make a body of
work for the last 25 years that um
deals with these ideas
i use a lot of inspiration from the
history of natural history i've worked
with scientists on projects
tom lovejoy he's a big inspiration he's
in the front row right here
stephen j gould peter ward so on and so
forth
these people i looked up to as
being basically storytellers about what
is really going on and this sort of
unofficial version of um
and the real version of how humans have
impacted this planet
um
let's see if i can get this to go
forward
there we go so obviously you can see the
enormous impact that humans have in
terms of warfare
but i also want to point out that when
humans waltzed out of africa
i don't know a million years ago or so
800 000 years ago wherever they went
they they created extinctions um
australia um north america so on and so
forth this is actually from chesley
bonastel's painting um right after world
war ii it's not of a nuclear explosion
in manhattan but it's part of a cycle of
imagining the unimaginable
this is a meteor impact in lower
manhattan he also did a cycle of of um
images that have to do with how
nuclear explosions would affect the
great cities of the world um these are
ways and chesley bonista is one of the
great astronomical
painter visionary painters of the 20th
century who worked in the film industry
as well as as well as working for nasa
made images about space before it was
possible to go into space to sort of
show
what was going to happen in a
scientifically informed way
this is another way that we look at the
history of the world the top images of
uh the polar ice caps in 1979 and the
bottom one i can't see it says 2 000 i
can't read it 2 000. we're close enough
anyway you seeing is believing
unfortunately um there's you know a
laundry list of images um but one of the
things that i'm fascinated by is how
humans have to have a disconnect with
these images what are the implications
of this stuff um obviously it's
terrifying but what does that mean in
our daily lives and how does that
interact with our culture
i still think it hasn't been reconciled
um and i'll show you a couple of images
that have to do with um you know parts
of the way that these ideas and images
have
have entered into our our language but i
still don't think we understand what the
implications are um obviously there's a
lot of attraction this being the week of
the titanic sinking centennial
the failure of technology and obviously
humans having a sense of their own
technological expertise and the reality
of the situation
obviously the history of
civilizations on
earth are you know littered with uh
situations where humans have
mysteriously disappeared well it's not
so mysterious once you look at the um
the resource equation um and obviously
our relationship to food
and um how we
digest pun intended the information
about where food comes from is still
very much
mostly swept under the rug
the same thing with with where power our
power comes from in terms of carbon
obviously wars are waged on behalf of
these
ideas and
you know they're they're they're wrapped
up in nationalism and all sorts of other
dynamics that i don't want to go into
obviously the history of hunting and
colonialism has a big impact on this
stuff as well so these are some of the
things that have affected our
relationship to the planet and um you
know i think science does a fantastic
job that the the greatest job in the
history of of human activity of telling
the story but because we're a visual
species i think we have a hard time um
visualizing these these ideas i'm going
to give you a little bit of a round up
of
some scientific images that have been a
big inspiration to me then i'm going to
show you some of my own paintings
this is a painting by charles r knight
from the field museum of
early life
on it looks like algae mats on the lower
right
obviously here's knight's late 19th
century version of apatosaurus when it
was believed that they were aquatic
there's niles eldridge's
wall of biodiversity at the museum
that's now about 15 years old and he's
been a big uh influence on me over the
years
obviously
ideas about extinction have entered into
our popular imagination this i believe
is the kt impact
hitting
czech celeb and then of course human
ancestry this is a reconstruction by
victor deak of australopithecus which is
a photoshop
sculpture hybrid and again we have a
chesley bonus dell image there was a big
inspiration for
not only the space program but also
destination moon george powell's 1950
science fiction movie
scientific illustration this is a sars
virus escaping a human cell
and reproducing these are all things
that have been a big influence on me
as well as some more popular culture
this is from planet of the apes
we won't go into the geology of the
pacific northwest and
manhattan schist
the abysmal day after tomorrow a
squandered opportunity if ever there was
one and soylent green um i think the
poster may be better than the movie but
uh
um
that's in case those those of you that
aren't familiar with the uh the uh
what soil and green is certainly green
is people um and then um another and i
say this um i've i have some affection
for for these movies i think actually
planet of the apes is brilliant but um
this is from i am legend as well as this
and you know i think that there's more
care that goes into these images and you
know digital set extensions and stuff
than go into any of the ideas in them
which is a big tragedy because um why
not spend an extra couple of
weeks you know working on the script um
once
i've i've put my finger in the the film
industry and i kind of understand why on
a certain level now but um it is i think
a squandered opportunity if ever there
was one um
whoops sorry about that
now we're going to show some of my
paintings if uh if we can get to them
here we go all right so the way i've
tried to cope with some of these i
these irreconcilable tensions over the
years is to make paintings about the
history of knowledge this is a painting
i made 20 years ago called evolution and
it's
an encyclopedia of some of the life on
earth and the history of life
it's 24 feet long um
ideas about um the gmo revolution and
the history of um uh artificial
selection you can see it going from left
to right um i'm also fascinated by the
history of you know art history
obviously the image before is heavily
um not only you could say influence it's
quoting not only church but the dioramas
that we were looking at earlier you know
the akeley hall the field museum the
great tradition of looking at nature um
which of course whenever i go to a
natural place now i'm secretly
disappointed that it doesn't look like a
diorama um
and it's very it's embarrassing um and
also the history of american art in
terms of we were looking at peel and
that's someone that definitely is the
great great grandfather of an image like
this
this is an image that comes from
let's say in less of an art historical
context it's not except for the sort of
1940s rothko look it's also from the
golden field guide of amphibian
evolution
so it's this collision between these two
seemingly disparate
interests
this is more foghorn leghorn than real
farm but um it's i mean all kidding
aside it is i mean i had a great time
making it and was laughing all the way
but it was also a way to try to show
that the ideas of what a species is and
what the species boundary is very
arbitrary and what is appropriate
behavior and what isn't in terms of
taking genetic information from one or
the other
and i have a lot of ambivalence about
those issues
i did a cycle about
the biosphere 2
in arizona in 1992 to 95
which imagined not only the biosphere
in arizona but it was also taking it
into outer space not well actually in
the solar system
not unlike silent running doug
trumbull's 1972 um
eco sci-fi
feature so um
ideas about time capsules and the arc
and so on and so forth have been
fascinating to me um and this sort of um
the hopefulness of gestures like that um
this is another image that's somewhat of
an encyclopedia these are some animals
that
i observed in guyana with mark who's
going to be speaking later when we went
to kaitura falls
this is a 16-foot painting many of these
paintings are very very large this is 16
feet
so this is really an encyclopedia of a
specific ecosystem in guyana
this is a
22-foot
mural in the department of fisheries in
seattle's lobby that is a history lesson
and a geography lesson of um some of the
most notorious extinctions in earth's
history
from humans leaving central africa to
avian malaria so um some of these
projects i set aside months to do
research for or read or talk to
scientists others um are more intuitive
but they all have a foundation in
the scientific ideas and natural history
this is from a project where um dorothy
and i went to madagascar
to look at some lemurs and
see some
remaining forest in the in the northeast
and
i was commissioned by the lemur
conservation society to make an image
that told the story of what was
happening there on some level and um we
eventually turned this in this image i
modified it slightly this is a painting
that's now in the lobby of the u.s
embassy in uh uh and antenna riva
um and
i couldn't resist showing proof that i
was actually there there's a brookesia
chameleon one of my very favorites um
that obviously is very good at
camouflaging itself in the in the leaf
litter um that was a particularly
nightmarish hike by the way um here's
purely fantasy uh somewhat of a
self-portrait um
contemplating our nearest ancestor uh
australopithecus
this is a painting that i actually
just showed in new orleans on the left
are invasive uh species that come from
all over the world invading a bayou
swamp in louisiana
and they're facing off against endemic
species of the american south
here's imagining different climate
change scenarios in central park
there's a street around the corner from
my studio
there's a long story that i won't go
into for this um i'm i'm rushing ahead a
little bit because i see my time is
almost up um
okay
that's pretty self evident you have a
snakehead china orientalist in the
center there
kudzu and the life cycle of
asiatic tiger mosquito you can't really
see it in the in it um
but uh it's in there
a couple of climate drawings these are
big oil oil drawings on paper that are
about
55 by 70 or 80 or so on and so forth
and then manifest destiny which i spent
many many well let's say a long time on
that imagines
climate
change affecting uh brooklyn looking
east and i worked with um james hansen
at the good art institute on some of the
data for this and this this i
this took many many years to formulate
it took about a year to paint but it's
24 feet as well here's a detail
so i guess in a lot of ways i make
history paintings about bad news
and
anticipating a
future that might be a little bit of a
challenge
so thank you very much
mark diane our next speaker has shown at
the museu at the miami art museum the
tate gallery and the museum of modern
art in new york city he has been
featured on the pbs series art 21 he's
exhibited here in connecticut at aldrich
contemporary art museum in 2003
his
cabinets of curiosities inspired by the
wonder cabinets of the 16th century
borrow the look of early scientific
collection displays
while calling into question the politics
and assumptions that these forms of
display reinforce please welcome mark
diane
i can start talking while you're setting
up i i think um my name is mark dime
nice to meet you all it's a great
pleasure to be in this audience i i
think i've never felt more at home
having uh worked a lot in philadelphia
with about some of the people that amy
talked about about
alexander wilson and and uh and and of
course the bartrams working with the
philosophical society um and uh uh and
many of the other institutions in
bartram's gardens of course uh and also
uh uh being a lifelong friend of alexis
and a lot of people who have inspired me
are in this room today
so i i make work which is largely
a consideration of of
uh the culture of nature and by that i
mean my work is largely unlike some
artists who are involved in a kind of
interrogation of of uh natural processes
my work is really about ideas about
nature and uh and
i think like alexis and and james prozac
as well our world view is very much
formed by science we are we are people
who take science uh very seriously that
forms our cosmology but at the same time
we recognize that science doesn't have a
monopoly on the discourse of nature and
that uh the the notion of nature is
culturally produced by a wide variety of
of people who have very different ideas
about about
what that is and that and that includes
people like hunters for instance
let me see if i can do this right
i want to show this is the uh instead of
talking about my work instead of giving
a kind of survey of of what i do i want
to give you a case study and that case
study is uh in 2007 i was invited by the
british museum of natural history in
london to be their artist in residence
and uh
and the british museum of natural
history of course you know is very high
on the pantheon of natural history
museums it has one of the greatest
collections has
enormous research facilities it has some
of the most important collections
and
they were very busy
thinking about what they were going to
do
for the
bicentennial of darwin's birth they were
so busy that they forgot about
celebrating 300 years of the birth of
linnaeus
and uh there's not a lot of
material culture around linnaeus
that hadn't been already uh taken up by
other places that were doing exhibitions
about linnaeus and lynas is 300 uh
birthday uh and so in 2007 they realized
that they they didn't have a plan for
what to do about this
they've had they've been a pioneer in
artist residency programs so they
thought instead of doing something about
linnaeus they would invite an artist to
come and make an exhibition that would
have some relationship to linnaeus to
systematics to taxonomy and that and
that and that would be me so
and and that's lynnette's and so uh
so i thought well this is an exciting
opportunity for me to work with the
natural history museum to have uh great
resources of this collection uh i've
been an artist in residence with many
scientific institutions and i always
know what i get out of it which is
access to expertise but i'm never sure
exactly what they get out of it
and so this was a kind of an experiment
to to try to work on that
uh
they have an an enormous gallery called
the gerwood gallery which is really
about the size of this entire floor or
actually it's maybe even bigger and uh
and so we wanted to organize an
exhibition that had something to do with
this and i was interested in
contemporary debates about systematics
not merely the historical element and
also the audience there is a very
popular audience one of the problems is
that this museum like many natural
history museums considers its audience
ever younger so um now the age i think
they shoot their ex their exhibition
designed for is like six or something so
uh and i was interested in making a a an
exhibition that was an adult exhibition
not an adult exhibition like adult film
exhibition but rather an adult an
exhibition that that people that
people my age might come and enjoy and
not feel uh condescended so
at the same time i wanted to deal with
these issues as an artist not as not as
a historian not as a scientist so i
created an exhibition which i start with
an introduction to linnaeus uh borrowing
a lot of what little material culture
there is actually i turned up a lot of
things that i think no one else would
have been able to find for instance the
cabinet there is the cabinet that
linnaeus's collection arrived in london
from
which has been because it has no
scientific importance it was entirely
neglected in the basement of the lenaian
society in fact when you open the vault
where all the specimens are kept you
bang the vault door into the cabinet so
they never thought about the cabinet as
a thing of material value or or cultural
value i also i think i'm the first
person to ever borrow actual linnaeus
specimens for exhibit so i borrowed
tobacco cannabis and coca plant
and exhibited those
as well as other historic
herbariums at the time and talked a
little bit about some of the competing
models
that existed for linnaeus's uh display
this is actually a every image i could
find of linnaeus within the natural
history museum so uh uh at times he's
looking remarkably handsome and virile
and other times uh very sagely and
owl-ish
there there are some of the specimens
again i borrowed various specimens so
you could see that there was not a
single standard to the to the herbarium
it was something still in formation
during during the period of linnaeus
so how do we look at what's going on in
systematics in 2007 there were a lot of
debates happening it was very very hotly
debated at the moment
because of this notion of the barcoding
of life
of the battles that were going on
between um um orthodox uh uh comparative
anatomy approaches to systematics and
and molecular approaches
uh and some people were taking very most
people were sort of in the middle saying
that well usually these things support
each other it's just another tool it's
great and other people like no it has to
be this way or it has to be with the new
technology so i thought well let's let's
let the public in on these debates in a
kind of fun way in a way that will
really engage them so we'll look at the
we'll look at the natural history we'll
look at the nature in london and we'll
do that through some very unusual ways
so we took this electric car we covered
it with sticky material and we drove the
longest road in london
we took that back and removed all of the
new insects we had collected on this
road
and uh and we divided those
blobby insects between the morphology
entomologist and the molecular
entomologists and they had a bit of a
contest as to see
what
what did we find and uh
and uh certainly the uh uh even though
some a lot of things were quite squished
the
the uh the people who were doing uh work
on competitive anatomy found out what
they had much quicker than the
morphology people and the morphology
people made a few mistakes like one
winged insect was came back as certainly
a grain of rice which we know wasn't and
so uh so we exhibited the car when we
exhibited uh the our our kind of
laboratory and also the uh some of the
of uh the cladograms of some of the uh
organisms that were found and some of
the conclusions that were drawn and and
we did find some things we found um a
south african beetle that certainly
should not have been in london and we
found lots of using this kind of ex
somewhat eccentric collection method
uh we found a lot of things that uh that
wouldn't wouldn't necessarily be known
in the city of london
and we worked i worked very very closely
with the entomologist and and all of
these projects were called field work
and they all dealt with sort of
contemporary issues within within london
things that people were really thinking
about and and very much about also
making the invisible world of london
visible
um
of course one of the big things in
london london had just won the bid for
the olympics um that was very much on
people's minds this is a um a soccer
field which was about to be destroyed to
make a soccer field for the olympics and
so working with with the botanist from
the museum
we did a square meter of
the soccer field looking at the
biodiversity in that soccer field which
i can promise you is not
terribly significant and then we walked
outside of the soccer field
across the street
and did another sample from the side of
the road
these were brought in
and
there were
i think four species
in the soccer field
and and there were dozens and dozens in
the other sample and we also let them
grow over the course of the exhibition
so we made a herbarium from
from uh what we found and we also
allowed those plants to grow so within
the three or four months of the
exhibition you really saw two very very
different
kinds of kinds of ecosystems side by
side
and of course one of the things that
that i'm very interested in is
is the aesthetics of science that you
know that there is a certain look to the
practice and there and when you go into
the laboratories there are certain
things that you know i i think
i've probably been in hundreds of
laboratories and i've never been in a
laboratory which lacked a far side
cartoon for instance
um
there we go
so that's the soccer field
and that's the side of the road
oops
um
the next project was to go to the grave
sites of three
19th century um social reformers uh
emmeline pankhurst um great suffragette
uh and uh karl marx and thomas huxley i
brought the entire
representatives from all of the uh
invertebrate
invertebrate biology teams and we did a
sample collection
in everything in on and around the
graves of these people
marx looks like a dwarf from the lord of
the rings
uh and so and so we did we we we sampled
the diversity
and uh used all of the ta all of the
feel techniques available to our experts
then we built into the laboratory this
collection of
we used the the very impressive imaging
laboratory
and created portraits of all of the
organisms
that we found comparing the sites as
though one could draw a conclusion of
course one cannot really draw much of a
conclusion from this or certainly not a
conclusion
that would be a standard conclusion
about the diversity
of invertebrates within the city of
london
so part of the um one of the things that
i think is is interesting about artists
what they add to this is artists have a
we have access to a different
vocabulary than scientists for instance
i i you know that we can use
uh metaphor and irony and humor in a
very in fact those are that those things
are our bread and butter and those
things are very difficult to use in a
scientific discourse so some of these
projects really amplify that that
difference amplify
you know whenever i'm doing these
projects i'm really shadowing aspects of
a scientific methodology but i'm not
reproducing science and i think that's
very clear for the scientists that i
work with
and here's our list and our our
portraits of our figures and that there
each one of these also has a video which
describes the methodology these all have
methodology and they all have goals and
they have
strategies
the last one was the field work on the
thames where we were working to help the
power station clean their filters
we found everything that we found in the
filter the
plants animals
and
what we i guess we could call material
culture was placed in this very
specially constructed this this this
worried people this one especially the
museum people the registrar was very
concerned about some of the things we
might be bringing into the museum uh and
uh so we built this safe secure tent in
order to house those things and in which
you could see everything with a very
obscured vision as as though through the
water itself and um that and there was
uh the front door had a slightly more
transparent view so you could go in and
sit you could look through that and see
sort of the various apparatus
and you could also um
see some of the specimens more carefully
again we did find things that were
unexpected we found the what is only the
second seahorse to be recorded in the
river thames and lots and lots of in
invasive things some new invasive things
that people didn't know had been were
there yet
um
and i don't know where these ducks are
from but they're certainly part of that
uh and so uh
you know for for me this this was an
exciting opportunity to be able to work
with uh with um
scientific professionals on that caliber
but also to be able to discuss
really introduce people to to
rudimentary ideas of systematics how
systematics work
how everything has a systematic doesn't
have to be biological entity there are
many ways of of developing relationships
between these things but also to talk
about some of those debates since
museums certainly do not arrange things
taxonomically now i you know i think
that systematics is an incredibly
important tool so it's not a as some
people might think a critique of
systematics which i think would be a
rather absurd endeavor in a way so um
that's just how i work with um
scientific institutions
i think that's it and i also we also
produced a field guide to the exhibition
itself uh which needed a field guide and
and this sort of fills in some of the
details of each of the
each of the endeavors it it uh
gives you the locations it gives you the
methodology and gives you some of the of
the statistics that were generated by
each of these endeavors so and i have i
have about 25 of these so if people want
they might be happy to give them away
thank you very much
um as i'm sure you know this symposium
would not have happened without james
prosec
artist and writer he's written for
numerous publications including the new
national geographic and the new york
times his books
from the early trout and illustrated
history
to his most recent eels an exploration
from new zealand to the sargasso of the
world's most mysterious fish
set the standard for a new generation of
natural history writing
an upcoming survey exhibition of his
work is scheduled at the addison gallery
of american art in andover massachusetts
please welcome james prosek
i guess i'll start talking well the
um presentation is being changed but uh
it's it's such a great pleasure to be
here with all of you um
friends
mentors influences
and
i
love things that go on at yale i was an
undergraduate here
my my work is based in natural history
stuff and i paint uh
i grew up painting birds and fish
my father was born in brazil he grew up
in a suburb of sao paulo
and he fell in love with birds as a
child
in brazil thank you
yeah we apologize for the brevity of the
pieces but we asked some of our favorite
people and they said yes so
but it's it's really wonderful uh to be
here um anyway my father fell in love
with birds as a child in brazil
and when he moved to this country at 14
he brought that love of birds with him
and to new rochelle new york and when i
was a kid growing up in southwestern
connecticut where i still live in a town
called easton i live a couple houses
down from the house where i grew up
it's relatively rural even though it's
50 miles or so from
new york city
my father used to bring home volumes of
audubon's bird paintings of north
america home from the local library
as well as a book of paintings by luis
agassi suertes who's
still one of my favorite bird painters
and i'd sit at the kitchen table and
copy these paintings over and over
and then at about nine years old um some
turbulent things were happening in my
family life and i my focus shifted from
birds to fish a rogue friend of mine um
who is a troublemaker at school
introduced me to fishing
and i fell in love with
i really fell in love with fish and in
particular
a type of fish called the trout which
many of you are familiar with
he brought me to
a little stream that goes into the
northern end of the eastern reservoir
this our town easton is blessed with
having parts or whole of four drinking
water reservoirs so there's a lot of
watershed land around the reservoirs and
there and i caught my first native brook
trout
at
about 10 years old and i just thought it
was the most beautiful thing i'd ever
seen in my life and it had
a red belly and
red spots with blue halos it looked like
a tropical fish and it lived in this
tannic dark
water that you couldn't see anything it
was a totally mysterious world
and i became totally obsessed with trout
the brook trout our native trout in
connecticut is actually a char which is
closely related to
the arctic char
but i as well as mark um
uh
and alexis are interes am interested in
um the history of how we name and and
classify the natural world so you'll
hear a little bit more about that if i
can get to it all but um
from about nine years old to 28 i was um
trout were just about everything i
thought of maybe girls and other things
but
um
and i started painting trout and i went
to the library when i was a kid looking
for a volume of
the trout of north america equivalent to
what audubon had done for birds and i
couldn't find one so i thought at 11
years old well i'll make a book on the
trail of north america
so i started writing letters to
departments of wildlife around the
country asking
um if
you know different people that studied
trout in some of the mountain states and
and they sent me all kinds of wonderful
biological papers and
and things and photographs of the
different trout and i started compiling
a list of all the trout and i based my
list of course at that age on
on fish that had been named by different
people
and through that research
getting looking for old books and
second-hand
book shops
like the american food and game fishes
by david starr jordan and walter everman
i became interested in the history of
how people
name things and
david star jordan was the first
president of stanford university and he
named a lot of the western trout
of north america
but i my list was was based on what i
could find and i didn't question whether
or not these were
real species or not whatever species was
i just painted them if someone had named
it but i soon learned that there was a
lot of
argument among ethiologists about what
trout were
species or subspecies or local varieties
or strains and i became very confused
and i had to make some decisions about
what fish to include in my with the book
i wanted to make
so i did and and when i was a freshman
here i proposed a book on the child
north american was lucky enough to find
a publisher i was planning on becoming
an architect and major in english
literature
but the book um i was lucky enough to
find a publisher and because of that i
just continued painting and writing the
same thing i've been doing since i was
five or six years old
so the the first book of trout was about
70 fish of north american 70 um types of
north american trout and then i thought
well i'll do try to do a book on the
trout of europe and asia and north
africa and
trouter only native to the northern
hemisphere i think the southernmost
native trout
isn't even below the tropic of
cancer in taiwan
but
as i traveled through
in particular central asia turkey and
kyrgyzstan and
kazakhstan i realized that nobody had
really
studied the the trout over there very
much
and i um
the in this but the second book of trout
i did which includes 100 paintings of of
trout from europe and asia north africa
about
more than a third of it is just
diversity within a single species
of trout the brown trout called salmo
trita the linnaean binomial
but in the process of making that book i
i thought what an injustice it is that
all this diversity is crammed within one
species name the brown trout salmo truta
and i i just started to kind of bother
me in in my travels mostly with this uh
amateur archaeologist from austria
johannes schiffman who's a baker by
profession
very strange guy but wonderful man
who publishes a
scientific papers in
a austrian fisheries journal we travel
for eight years together to many
interesting places some of them
politically turbulent southeast turkey
we were looking for trout in the
headwears of the tigris river which we
didn't get um because the turkish army
was fighting the kurdish gorillas and
wouldn't let us into the headwaters we
wanted to go
but he went back a couple years later
and did catch and photograph the first
trout from the headwires of the tigris i
could go off in different tangents but
i'll try to stay focused
the tigers fish is particularly
interesting because it's uh at the
headwaters of the
um the tigris which flows to the indian
ocean there were never
trout in the indian ocean so they
crossed from headwaters of other other
places like the caspian and the black
sea and the mediterranean so they're
actually kind of a hybrid of the
anyway um i didn't mean to get into a
trout dissertation
just don't ask me about eels i'll never
stop talking
but
these are just a
sort of a smattering of some of the fish
that i painted for that book which came
out in 2003. these are actually all
types of brown trout i hesitate to use
the word subspecies because i have
issues with all those monikers and with
the linnaean system which
as mark said people have offered um
uh alternatives to
like the philo code which michael
donahue and jacques gautier here at yale
have pioneered with um
kevin de kiros at the smithsonian which
would pretty much eliminate all the
higher ranks of the linnaean system
the
family phylum i didn't even know them
but they don't really
matter that much in my mind because
they're not real entities they're just
they're just categories we fit nature in
because our mind likes to put things in
hierarchies it but it works it's worked
so well for so long because it conforms
to the way the human mind works but is
there a better system i'm not sure
i'm writing an article for national
geographic right now about the future of
taxonomy so i'll be inquiring about this
stuff but
an alternative may not be in sight the
the internet does allow us to have sort
of more web-like
um interaction and and may be able to
handle some of the complexities
um of biological reality that that we're
coming to know faster and faster now in
the last decade
i any one of these points i could
continue going on but i have like 70
images
this is adam and eve
adam of course as the story goes is the
first namer god gives him the um
the uh privilege or the he it's his
first task in the garden is to name
everything and depending on whatever
translation you whatever way you want to
translate it it's sort of a way of
taking control of the animals in the
garden there's a great story by ursula
le guin called she unnames them where
eve goes through the garden unnaming
everything that adam names and when
she's finished she hands her name back
to adam and says see you later
so it was sort of a feminist
thing in the i think it was in the 80s
it was like a one-page story in the new
yorker it's really beautiful but i can
hand out copies later
as as mark um and alexis are i'm
interested in
the history of exploration and bob and
amy and everybody here um kristoff uh
i i'm interested in this time when um we
started going abroad and merchant
companies started building ships that
were capable of going to far-off places
collecting spices and riches and they
came back with all this stuff from
overseas and that's really what made
linnaeus necessary because you know
europe northern europeans only needed to
know
200 or so different
animals before
all this all this stuff started coming
in from the tropics and overwhelming
northern europe and somebody had to step
up and create a system to name it all
and classify it all so we could you know
communicate about nature and as as much
as i don't like the the um
idea of species or the name species
because i think it caused a lot of
trouble with policy making and stuff
like the endangered species act does
that mean you can't you can't protect
something that's not a species and
and what if nobody can define what a
species is because nobody can and it's
different from fish to birds to
coral to plants
it's become a real a real problem
it was something else i was going to say
but i'll keep going
just this is the reach of the feyo say
the dutch east indies company they just
went everywhere they brought all this
stuff back and these great pictures were
being made this is a famous picture of a
rhinoceros by durr
who drew it from just rumors of a
rhinoceros that sunk on a ship i think
on its way to lisbon
but i i'm trying to go back to a time
before uh these standard systems
existed because i think along with these
standard systems come an assumption that
they're actually real but they're i
don't think they they're based on
reality and the lineage system has been
flexible enough to accommodate
the things we've learned through
molecular
research and genetic stuff but a cabinet
of curiosity there
i have uh i've been talking 10 minutes
is that or less
just a beautiful picture of a seaweed
from an exhibition at the yale center
for british art a couple years ago
called ocean flowers which were
commissioned by british people in india
i think and may be mistaken but were
made by
um south people who are trained in the
southeast asian miniature tradition um
and geometry is a big part of those um
pictures they make so they compose the
seaweed in incredible ways when you hold
sea breeze just like wet hair there's no
way to really
draw it but and when these pictures came
back to england they influenced the
history of natural history painting from
then on
bird of paradise this is maria sibilla
mariam's painting of a
white witch moth the caterpillar is
incorrect um christoph and i one of our
dreams is to find the the caterpillar of
the white witch moth because it's
unknown but it's been assumed that it's
known because of this painting until a
couple years ago when we realized nobody
really knows what it is this is i'm glad
it's not the same picture of linnaeus
mark had but that's the i think the
title page of the first edition so
around 28 years old i
i'd painted as many trout as i could
sort of stand i guess and um i thought
well now i want to comment on uh
our relationship to nature a little bit
more and
and through the avenue of contemporary
which is a very peculiar world um i
think
but but a world where you can
navigate with ideas and really have fun
thinking
and not necessarily have to be
associated with the university but i
started making these hybrid pictures of
creatures that became their names in
protest of being named like a parrot
fish and a turtle dove and a kingfisher
and and i put little things next to them
that are sort of like you know a
duck trout i don't think there's such a
thing but
some people say wow is there really a
sea pegasus or
flying fox
with the collector's tool at the bottom
this is then i did some tool birds this
is a cockatoo it has
a crest of a swiss army knife
because humans the commentary about
conservation we tend to
conserve things that are useful to us so
these these creatures evolved to mimic
human industry in order to survive
this is a drill duck
this is a sailfish
um and then i started doing these things
in traditional natural history painting
you have the
common and scientific name of the
creature underneath it
so i i took the names away and replaced
them with these curvilinear lines which
to me expressed the the place of the
creature in the ecosystem without having
to name it the sea dragon
that's a fuertes painting that i copied
and put some lines around it
um pheasants and then i did this mural
at the aldrich contemporary art museum
which is a i blew up the end papers of
roger tory peterson's field guide to
birds where there's silhouettes and
numbers and you're supposed to match the
numbers up with the names to identify
them
so i left the numbers and took out the
name so nobody could
could identify them
this is our beloved peabody where i've
been going since i was five years old
and now i've been lucky enough to
help out with things the the dioramas of
course and i and as part of this naming
inquiry i wanted to go on a collecting
trip uh with a museum as soon as i found
out they were still doing it which i
couldn't really believe they still went
in the jungle and with nets and guns and
it seemed that would have been my
perfect job description if i'd lived in
the 19th century but i now i because
that job description doesn't really
exist i have to kind of comment on it so
i went christoph organized it um
expedition to suriname
here i didn't even know where sure name
was before
i went on this trip but we saw some cool
stuff
and
moths there's a white witch that maria
siblimarium painted
snakes it's going into the pot i don't
know if we ate it
but beautiful stuff that i painted
christoph found a new species of bird
which he's still in the process of
naming so i was able to see naming first
hand
this is kristoff and burnt heinrich a
great writer who was on the trip
and
just killing and painting things
but i loved it it was amazing um i i
i'll i'll wrap up in the next 30 seconds
i hope
this is uh i i like alexis and mark also
like to go into the field as part of my
research for my writing and my painting
and i have a book coming out about
paintings of ocean fish but i wanted to
paint them all life size from individual
fish not a species not not a painting to
represent a species in a field guide but
an intimate relationship i had with a
particular fish
so i went on this harpoon boat in nova
scotia off nova scotia and george's bank
there's a
swordfish dorsal fin over his left
shoulder the harpooner you stuck the
harpoon in there's the swordfish the
harpoon head went right through and
there's the swordfish
anyway
i painted them life-sized so i could
show some of the abstract beauty of the
of the different fish
these are just some of them i think mark
caught that one and
grouper i mean i i think a grouper's an
amazing looking fish
um and then i get to put silhouettes in
the end papers which is yeah
there's and then i just the last couple
i've been doing taxidermy versions of
some of the tool creatures and hybrids
because in the natural history museum
the dead thing is the proof of its
existence so um some people actually
think there's a drill duck now in a
sleeping flying fox
um and these are the most recent things
i've been making taking an existing bone
like a cow vertebra and building an
extension of it that that shows where it
might have gone if it had given the
opportunity um there's an antler where i
connected the tines
and these are some
of those anyway that's my talk thank you
very much
um carolyn nemcheck is going to talk
about conservation and art she serves as
the vice chair of the open space
institute vice chair of the conservation
campaign is on the board of the trust
for public land she sits on the advisory
boards of the yale school of forestry
and environmental science the yale
institute for biospheric studies and the
land trust alliance please welcome
carolyn
sure
i also am really happy to be here very
grateful for the chance to talk about
one of my favorite things which is
preserving land
so my topic is art and land conservation
and we're going to start with a quote
that is at the entrance to the
smithsonian's museum of american art so
it acts as the context and focus for all
of the art on the ground floor and the
second floor all of which is landscape
painting and uh here's the quote
it's pretty amazing
because what we find is
well it's partly covered
what we find is um
there was pretty much a good sense of
confidence that we were a garden and to
me a garden
obviously in 1901 we'd already sullied a
lot of it and this is part of what led
john muir whose quote this is
to cooperate and teach teddy roosevelt
quite a bit about what needed to be
preserved and set aside in different
kinds of gardens but what we have found
in the last 111 years
since this quote is that
our definition of what our land is is
much more complex involves a lot of
other things than just being considered
a garden or something even that is just
about natural resources that we could
exploit and use so beyond from this
early period having forests which are
perceived as
timber and trees and lumber or fields
which were farms and food we also now
have
a host of things as all of you know the
concern about climate change
how resilient will we be what happens
with biodiversity and so on artists and
land conservation groups are responding
to that new complexity and what we're
finding is that
a lot of natural preservation groups
started out saying well we've got to
preserve for biodiversity the trend now
is to say we know we just have to do
preservation we're not exactly sure that
we're always going to be hitting the top
most important aspect but if people say
they want to preserve it we probably
should preserve it it means they'll come
up with some money to do it and likewise
artists are saying i'm not exactly sure
what it is that is most worrisome to me
or most opportunistic to me and what i
can do with this concept i have of land
and the complexity of our fragile world
but i'd like to
begin to approach it and work with it
sometimes in the landscape as well so
i'm going to look at some of the
net results of this
recently we now have
747 million or so acres preserved in
this country that's 20 percent of the
land mass
those have been for multi-purposes
sometimes it's about protecting water
food working landscapes of other sorts
playgrounds dog parks are the most
rapidly growing type of park
that's risen by 34 in the last couple of
years people like their off-leash dog
parks because they're having fewer
children or they're empty nesters
artists also have come at this from
multiple
perspectives as we've seen and i'd like
to focus on two in the new york region
so that you could actually go visit them
if you wanted to or see something about
their work i've got these two brochures
out on the hallway next to where james's
art is uh got little
sign up sheets if you would like to buy
some of the art that's out there and
these will tell you something they're
sort of guides to what's going on in
some of the projects i'll talk about so
pick those up the two artists are
deborah friedman
a painter born in 1947 and george
trackus an environmental artist born in
1944 they both work in this region you
don't have to travel to marfa texas or
to the spiral jetty to see something
about this work
so we've got two ladies here the one on
the right is deborah friedman this is
actually taken just a couple of weeks
ago out at the new site of the fdr4
freedoms memorial that's designed by
louis khan it's only being realized now
as you know khan died in the 70s but
this is a major undertaking they have
raised most of the money all of the
masonry is now in place it is a
phenomenally beautiful site and i would
urge you to go actually doesn't have
anything to do with what i'm talking
about but i happen to be there in the
pictures of debra
so what she has done is in her work is
taken the more traditional view and
stuck with the media that's painting and
printmaking she does monotypes and she
does uh
oil painting mostly but these are of a
size and scale that fit on a wall and
can go in a museum
and are really uh sort of an extension
of the earlier 19th century concern with
the sublime in the american landscape
deborah basically started out with a
good deal of up close
in forest paintings waterfalls trees
there was almost no horizon line but 9
11 actually deeply affected her and she
began to paint what she called disturbed
landscapes and she took more seriously
what it meant to have preserved land
near where she lived out in the
countryside this is the shoken reservoir
which is part of the system that
preserves water for new york city's
drinking
so
she began to get herself to these sites
spend a lot of time on them and paint
them over and over this current series
and i'm just going to show you the two
are from
a series she calls good night irene
and this is based on the hurricane irene
which of course was ironically named
since it wasn't in any way ironic and
it further disturbed her because she
felt now we had not we've gone beyond
the concerns that she had about how to
keep the water safe and clean access to
those reservoirs open because of concern
about terrorists and the
civil
oversight that clamped down on access to
the reservoirs after 9 11 but now we
also were facing a great good deal of
uncertainty about the impact of nature
and what would happen when hurricanes
ripped through and destroyed towns her
interest was really to be able to
say in this series i'm concerned about
my small towns i'm not sure that we can
really say good night irene you know as
in put you to bed irene and get rid of
you
but her worry that the devastation might
return is still causing a good deal of
artistic interpretation that's
abstract and that has a heightened sense
of worry and concern i think there's a
good deal of that um certainly in
alexis's work but in others where people
are
saying are you are you awake are you
paying attention is this going to make
you move and do something this obviously
is not in any way a road map
but
i'm going to turn now to george trakkus
who's actually taken this art as many
artists have outside of the museum so he
doesn't work in drawings or paintings he
jumps outside and he gets to work in the
landscape it's what i like to think of
as
analogous to slow food it's slow art he
goes out into the landscape builds a
little boat putters around in the water
really gets to know the place and then
comes up with
some ideas about what he could do on the
land
so
i'm going to go through three of them
chronologically
this is beacon landing
this is very accessible it's in new york
right near um
the dia beacon and dia beacon was
instrumental in getting this place
started because cena hudson one of the
great land trusts in the hudson valley
had purchased some land and was going to
preserve it and the dia beacon people
said rather quietly to some of us
involved in art
well we're not sure that scenic hudson
has ever really considered art when it's
had a park or if they have we've never
seen evidence of it so we were hoping
that since this is really relational to
our new museum that you would help us
find an artist who can handle the
development of this site
the site itself is 22 acres it was an
abandoned
railway shunting yard it was all
landfill and as with much of where
george works it's been abandoned misused
abused it's often quite polluted and he
came into the site
again did his stuff at the boat began to
meet people in the area and got to work
with permitting and as he says his
process is actually really loves to
engage with people including the army
corps of engineers they don't frighten
him at all he was told that it would
take him years to get the permits but in
fact it took him about four months
so he works very closely he gets out
there that this is that's his car so he
drives up and down sometimes he's on the
train it's a little um hut so he has a
safe place to be when the weather is
stormy on the hudson and you're seeing
the back side of a sign that you saw on
the front side on the other one just a
little bit of it there on the side and
it basically says there are dangerous
cables under this water no one may
anchor here so you're not allowed to
move that sign it has to stay
so he integrates it into what he does
that's the inside of the hut where he
spends a good deal of time different
people he's found in there sleeping
when he shows up but here we already
have the
the integration of what he does so he
takes the environment as he finds it
works with it in order to anchor it into
place
uh and give it some uh reminiscent
feeling of the original shoreline
he accounts for
now we're seeing the
laying of the planking on top of all
that infrastructure of steel but he
gives the water a space to move for high
tide and low tide you can get to this
water in a wheelchair
not that you have to be in a wheelchair
but it is
absolutely counter intuitive to what
usually happens in a park by seeing a
hudson or anyone else which along the
hudson has to conform to permitting and
is usually built with a 13 foot high
bulkhead wall in order to be ready for a
100 year storm event and to
keep people safe and like mark was
saying with the
registrar at the
london museum people are incredibly
afraid of the water they consider it
very dangerous so this was a really
maverick thing for him to do and he felt
quite an accomplishment to be able to
get
access and as soon as the place is built
it fills up with people
and they come out uh in fact it's
beginning to surprise
and sort of annoy
the caretakers because they're not quite
sure these are school classes this group
is here talking to the crabbers who are
showing them
how their crabbing works
there are more people there than anyone
thought would be there here's a little
boy if you were to turn to the right he
would see this
george makes it very possible to get to
the water to sit down to stroll to
lounge and they really are getting many
more people than they ever thought they
would have
another site that he's worked in
is in new york city the land here is
obviously much more valuable but in fact
this is in an area where
no one wanted this land it's on
new newtown creek and that's what it's
known as the newtown creek water
treatment facility the new town creek
park itself is about two acres of built
space but it sits around like an outer
edge that people can get to around a
water treatment plant that handles 600
million gallons of water a day it's one
of new york city's 14 water treatment
plants you probably know the one that
you pass when you're on the west side
highway that they build off of harlem
and that involved a lot of community
attention and activity this one also
involved some community activity this is
very blighted part of northern brooklyn
and the community per se
said during the original meetings that
george went to what do you mean you're
going to make a park and we're not going
to be part of it how are we going to get
to it there's no access what do you mean
it's only for the people who work in the
water treatment plant no no no we have
to have access so george came up with a
way to get into it this is his ideal of
how it will be used over time again you
see the steps going down to the water so
you can get in and out of your
vessel
but the way you get to it is by going to
a dead end parking your car there are
about 20 parking spots because there's
no mass transit there
and you go in through a series of gates
that are very reminiscent of highly
stylized waves and there are light
features that are about nautical
elements you go up and over the plant
itself
it's about 740 feet of walking as you
get to one end you turn around and you
see the empire state building so you're
really located in new york city
you should know where you are when you
see this
you turn back heading north and you come
down toward the water
and again you've got these wonderful
spaces on both sides of the steps those
are little hand rails he was very
responsive to people in the community
they said they they knew he loved water
so what was he going to do to other than
getting them access to the water these
hand rails are h2o molecules
you see them
and again he's got these long steps
which remind me he says they don't have
anything to do with it but they remind
me of the gats in india where you go to
the sacred river
in order to really commune with the
water and where the water will take away
all of your sins
so he says no it's not really about that
it's just to get to the water and hear
the hear the lapping
and be part of it this particular water
is actually kind of dangerous there are
signs all over that he could not have
them take out that say
pregnant women watch out children watch
out nobody should touch it nobody should
eat anything from it
so there's a whole lot of scolding going
on around here
you turn the corner and he's got these
big boulders that they found on the site
and you walk back in
and they're native plants they're places
to sit
and there's a
there's six different spots where you
could have a dock and you can tie up on
these bollards and again find a place to
sit now the last one is in
queens and it's in socrates park which
maybe some of you know about that was
started by isamo naguchi and mark de
souvero
in the 60s de souvero is uh
maybe a little more famous now because
one of his statues was in zuccotti park
so when the occupy wall street people
were there the big red statue kind of
became part of what people were seeing
but in the background here you'll you
will see not only a construction crane
but to the right of the crane some of
mark's work
this is what the park looks like today
it's got a lovely spring going on here
this is just about a week ago i was out
there and you can see that there's guys
sitting on the far side of the fence
because he jumped the fence he doesn't
want to sit back and this is a very
human tendency to want to get right to
the water
he's actually sitting up sort of high
this is what the
shoreline looks like around there you
can see that sort of the green scum
that's the rise and fall
of the tidal action there this is
looking toward
roosevelt island so you're looking
straight west maybe you'll see the
city court building in the background
with a diagonal roof
this is very very typical of new york
city's waterfront
it's
you know 650 or so miles of riprap
that keeps you back if it's not looking
so great it looks like this falling
apart and if it's looking pretty good
it's actually stabilized rip wrap with a
railing and you may be allowed to go to
it and look out over but again don't go
too near so
a big part of what
george trackus is offering is the
ability to get into the water
but he's also offering the opportunity
and this is done by the naguchi museum
and the curators there to have the
artist in a
environmental setting that involves the
entire community and
these are visioning sessions that four
different artists
are involved in
and then george chose this project so
there's george at the site this is very
typical there's a lot of
cyclone fencing keeping people away
he's got his generator so that he can go
down below and put the stuff in he's
almost always on site if you happen to
go before he opens this on may 13th
you'll probably see him there
you get down to the water level and you
see that he's those pins are now holding
some of this
these piers they're nine columns
and he's calling it sunyan
as a pun on union
at this this is very typical so he will
again you can see the historic remnants
of seaworthy craft and piers that are
there that's a big boathouse in the back
that isn't used for boats anymore
and
back to this final shot simply because i
think what this does is show that
degraded landscapes can be preserved
they can have an artistic element to
them that really allows people to come
in they didn't even know that they
wanted to be there it's surprising
everybody when he asked high school
students that came have you ever been
down to this water they said no of
course not you know we're inside
watching tv and doing our video games so
it is actually doing a lot of what we
know
needs to be done and it's happening
almost despite ourselves thank you
uh
christoph zizkovsky is a distinguished
ornithologist
and collections manager at the peabody
museum of natural history at yale he has
been in love with birds since he was a
child growing up in poland and his
happiest in the field collecting trips
to exotic parts of the world
his um
his main research interest is in the
evolutionary patterns of nest
architecture and tropical tropical
songbirds please welcome christoph
zaikovsky
good evening and
james thank you for
inviting me to
speak today
uh i am not an artist as you know from
my introduction and i just wanted to
tell you a little bit about the field
guides as from the perspective of a user
and
also as a person who accommodates
artists i actually
always invite artists as much as i
invite scientists to visit the peabody
collections and thank you
and get to
meet and discuss certain problems that
artists face when they work on field
guides i also through my travel to some
of these places that most people cannot
point on the map
feel like i'm contributing maybe a
little bit to
a
better understanding of the ranges of
species and
clarifying some of the issues
surrounding species limits that james
was alluding to
so
for example for the country of suriname
there is still not a bird field guide
available
so that's
definitely a hope for somebody to fail i
will
mostly talk about bird guides obviously
because of
this is a vast
area
this photograph shows our curator of
birds and the professor in the ecology
and evolutionary biology department rick
pram in the field with his students from
the ornithology class
helping them identify birds
this is ecuador so the field guide is
especially chunky because that's one of
the countries with the
biggest number of bird species
normally field guides are defined as
more portable
small packet size almost
books are increasingly now some digital
devices
that allow you to identify
plants animals or some other natural
objects
in the field
from a distance frequently
so it was quite a challenge to find
actually what would be the oldest field
guide available for north america for
example
from some online research i found this
book by florence miriam bailey
this is from 1889 and if any of you
actually know earlier examples i would
love to know
this particular book uh
it could be called a field guide because
of its small
size and because it explicitly talks
about field marks and using binoculars
the title
birds through
an opera glass
implies that the optics will be used
and but the illustrations are not
particularly useful for field
identification some of
some of the people who actually work in
the same
businesses myself like frank chapman
from the american museum of natural
history also
attempted to
create field guides and are sometimes
called pioneers
for field guides to birds this
particular book is from 1924
what bird is that and it actually shows
immediately
that he
most likely used museum collections to
generate these
images you can actually see that some of
the perches are exactly as those you
would find in museum on museum shelves
with taxidermied
mounts
the idea of field guides this is a
different kind of art and especially the
early ones often group their subjects
not according to some sort of scientific
principle like phylogenetic relatedness
but often by overall similarity in the
example on the left you actually see
north american thrashes
contrasted with some other brown streaky
lbjs as we call them
and
those on the left represent at least
four different families
i actually personally prefer the ones
organized phylogenetically
but i understand why for somebody who's
a beginner this would be an important
way to learn
the birds
this example on the right is another way
of doing this where you actually group
the birds
by season in this case these are all
immature warblers as they will be seen
in the fall if you actually attempted to
identify that's one of the biggest
challenges to brothers in north america
and they as you can see are grouped by
those that have spots in their tails and
those that don't and also by the stratum
of the forest so all these little clues
are great help when you actually attempt
to identify these
this is a page from one of the guides i
used as i was growing up back in poland
by deselberger and
this is what some people critique or
call it
jokingly as a cookie cutter art
but amazingly this actually works pretty
well for
bird identification in the field having
this kind of simplified image and very
predictably arranged
birds all face one direction you can
actually easily compare build sizes and
tail lengths and so on
so that actually works well
so a different approach to
creating images for field guides is to
actually
create scenes like sort of museum
dioramas where you actually
put multiple
images of a species within
the context of their
sort of average habitat
and this is an example from a european
bird guide by a swedish artist lars
johnson
with two species of owls that share
their habitat in up in
well scandinavia and northern europe
as all of you know
here in north america roger tory
peterson who's actually
native to connecticut uh who was native
lived in old line
who is often
considered the father of modern field
guides to birds and in general to
repopularize the idea of field guides
for other
plants and animals
so his major innovation was to include
these arrows
you can actually
see in the example on the left from the
original edition of his book
that these not only include the arrow
pointing to some
most important in his mind feature in
the field
to look at but also explain with the
text what it is so it's not just
pointing at the bill but also says look
at the color rather than shape
on the right this is from a later
edition and this is what we have seen in
the field guides for the last maybe 30
years
is to use these arrows without the
descriptor and
putting a lot of more text in the
on the page in the opposite page to the
plate
i actually prefer the other system and i
was really happy
to see that this it came it came back
with the publication of some of these
new generation field guides for europe
and north america
this is my
my most favorite field guide
and it's actually a work of two brits
and two swedes
kilian mularney and then setterstrom are
the artists and these are the people who
uh
for me earn a lot of respect for
spending a lot of time in the field
knowing the birds extremely well and
also being extremely
familiar with the i guess techniques to
use to depict these
so some of the innovations here in
addition to these arrows and text is
that they also often put a little insert
with the habitat
these birds occupy i purposely put here
these drop birds because this is one of
the biggest challenges for
identification in the field these
acrocephalous warblers in europe and
having these tools combined with the
descriptions of songs
it
these slight differences in shape and
some features like primary extension
basically how far the primary feathers
of the wing extend beyond the
tertials or secondaries
that's actually something that in the
past was used mostly
only when you had a specimen in hand but
now increasingly with good optics we can
actually even use this in the field
so many of you may have seen the
princeton oops
edition of this field guide and this is
uh it has gone already through one
improved edition and this is once a guy
that i would recommend if you ever
travel to europe or middle east or
northern northern africa um
the north american equivalent
is the
sibley guide
and this is
david allen sibley from massachusetts
whose father was my predecessor here at
the peabody museum and
he single-handedly painted
all birds of north america in multiple
views
this is again
what i love about these new guides that
these
images are arranged in very predictable
systematic way where you have the adult
male in a predictable position so you
can easily compare species a to species
b
again sometimes certain features that
are included in insets are
those obscure little
things that normally were used only in
hand and now
again you can actually photograph these
birds in the wild and often
see how wide the primary feathers are
and
this
is just one example of many uh pieces of
art that is out there there are now
something in the order of 700 field
guides to birds
published these are some of the
newest pieces of art from our own
michael d georgio
who's one of the artists who visits the
peabody museum and
he actually is now participating in a
big project illustrating all the
non-pastoring
birds of south america with guy tudor
and bob ridgely
so the plate on the left is actually
from this work
and it's not yet published but he allows
allow me to
show this
this is all based on people museum
specimens and photographs and other
resources that
these days artists use
a lot of work goes into this
and
one of the
important aspects of this work is
visiting the collections and actually
seeing these three-dimensional
specimens
james mentioned the same thing for
for some of his artwork that he also
likes to
see these
physical
versions so this is just the study of
the ivory-billed woodpecker
and james himself in the field on one of
these expeditions that we've organized
to the peabody
this is another good way to
get to know the birds and
paint them well
so some of you may be wondering why not
use photography why go through all this
trouble when you already have to paint
these virtually every standard way
there's not much room for creativity why
would artists bother to
illustrate these field guides with
paintings and that's again what
something that james mentioned is
averaging in his oceanic fishes project
he mentioned that he would actually
illustrate them based on a single
individual and he actually cared that it
was this individual
in field guides what you actually would
want is some sort of average you
actually look at a lot of images or
observe a bird in different contexts and
then summarize this all into one image
and it's really difficult to do
with photography here is an example of
one of the
recent guides to birds of north america
by ken kaufmann
and his attempt to
show thrashes for something as brown as
these trashies were it's critical to
know the exact shade of brown and
some
features of the facial or the spotting
some of this pattern it's really
difficult to show this
in a successful effective way
and
only slight improvement is when you
actually get include multiple images of
the same species as richard crossley
has done in his recent field guide it's
only last year's
book i invite you all to look at this
because some of these compilations are
really
fantastic to look at but it's not really
a field guide it's a pretty heavy 1.6
kilogram book
that you would use put it in in your car
as you go bird watching and then refer
to when you come back from your walk
and
as you can expect field guides are going
digital as everything
and by now you can already choose among
several options for your phone apps
you can
actually the power of these is that
unlike paper field guides you can
actually have an option of
searching by vocalizations for example
you can keep your life list in the same
device you can submit records
as use
encounter birds
and there are very
cool ways of kind of
almost dichotomous keys where you punch
in
what you see color shape
season
state or province and eventually it
comes up with very few options of what
this could be
so in conclusion i just wanted to invite
you to look at this website
diane schmidt out of the university of
university of illinois in
urbana-champaign she put together this
rather exhaustive database of field
guides to everything
and you can see from these categories i
don't know if you can actually read
these numbers but the birds she has
over 1200
guides
and the second are plants with
721
wildflowers
so i guess that's representative that
we're talking about birds today and
birds are still number one for the field
guides
there is even
and
there are some guides that you can use
to identify bird poop or road kills
that's only half serious
and if you are going to some of those
places for which guides are not
available there is now a way to download
images for example the
handbook of birds of the world project
out of barcelona spain
lynx editions are promising to make
available to
to subscribers all their digital image
versions of the images that they
generated in producing this series so in
the 16 volumes they managed to
illustrate all 10 000 species of birds
of the world so now you can
easily
use your
ipad or something to generate your own
guide and use it in the field so that's
all i have thank you very much